Tom Brady New England Patriots we're one
week away from Tom Brady being allowed
to officially entertain offers from
other teams we are nine days away from
him being able to sign with another team
Charlie Weis who was an assistant coach
in New England when Tom Brady arrived he
said last week on Sirius XM NFL radio he
has been texting with Tom and he shared
the outcome of the text exchange that he
was able to share because I guess there
was some language in there that he
couldn't repeat I don't usually pass
along these conversations why said but
one thing Tom told me nobody knows
anything so anyone who is telling you
they know they don't know and and look
that's a fair observation from Charlie
Weis and Tom Brady but Chris it got me
to thinking nobody is saying they know
that's why it's a story nobody knows
there's nobody out there saying I know
where Tom Brady's gonna go we're all
guessing and speculating because they've
given us nothing that we can wrap our
arms around a week before he's able to
officially start taking offers from
other teams no well you're right they've
given us nothing but we've got Inklings
I mean hey first off I mean we do know
something I mean we you know I I do feel
like we you know we saw Mike Vrabel
being facetimed on the front row you
know during free agency when he was with
Julian Edelman and Jimmy Fallon I mean I
don't think that was like totally an
accident I don't think it was like hey
let's call good old Mikey and see what's
going on I mean that was either planned
or drummed up to get interest going with
free agency drive the conversation
whatever it may be or maybe it was hey I
talked to verbal last night and we were
talking about me going to the Titans let
me check in with him today and see how
things are going I don't know you know
so yes we don't know but we have
Inklings and we have nobody dispelling
some of the very crucial rumors we're
hearing out there right now you know one
Tennessee but come on the 49ers thing I
mean it just it just it reeks of
realness it reeks of it you know we have
some of our most important NFL insiders
have gone dark on the biggest subject in
football right now and that that's a
clue to me right there hey hey glad you
said that okay I tried to explain that
to big cat on Friday he's got this weird
theory that the 49ers are using this on
certainty to squeeze Jimmy Garoppolo to
redo his deal I mean that's not how you
treat your franchise quarterback you
don't play those kind of games with
Jimmy Garoppolo and if you feel like you
need to squeeze him because maybe he's
not living up to his contract that's all
the more reason to go after Tom Brady
Yeah right right you're right I'm
squeezing
yeah go ahead god there's a problem if
you're squeezing him there's a problem
yes and there's a way to fix the problem
this year because there's an
unprecedented number of free agent
quarterback savais LeBeau that's why I
wasn't buying his logic and I tend to
agree with you the fact that that chef
teah hasn't said boo when he's got a
foot in every camp out there right and
he hasn't knocked it down or build it up
or said anything about it he plead
lockdown over it that tells you there's
something going no doubt about it yeah
that's you know and I know you and I
texted about this over the weekend a
little bit too but to me that's one of
the number-one clues out there that
something is real and substantial
between Brady and the 49ers I mean Adam
Schefter went to Michigan he's kind of
always on the forefront of Brady news
right there's a connection there you
know you also wrote a connection to John
ye-yeah connection to Don he exited on a
connection to Mike Shanahan helped him
write a bike a book you know so there's
a bike I had a bite of life I'd
everybody taught of how to ride the bike
- hey chef - help me ride a bike and
we'll do the book in the meantime and in
between yes to me that's a clue where
I've said that to a number of my friends
to go oh you don't think it's real then
the fact that the number one insider
gossip guy in football has gone crickets
on the subject is more of a sign than
anything to me that it is real and he's
hamstrung or a guy like shefter and
other insiders because they can't say
anything because they know the truth
from both sides so they're not saying
anything and that's that's what it kind
of tells me at least yeah I agree with
you and as I said last week there's an
easy way for the 49ers to knock all this
down they just need to come out and say
- right there's three different ways you
do it one issue a statement saying that
Jimmy Garoppolo is our guy and any talk
of any other quarterback coming here
instead of Garoppolo is fake news to put
Kyle Shanahan or John Lynch on the radio
Bay Area or nationally to say the same
thing or three
start telling the players start telling
them because if you tell them it's going
to get to the media that the 49ers brass
are informing players that they're not
going to pursue Tom Brady one or more of
those options is the way to kill this
and here we are a week into this chatter
and the 49ers have done have said have
tried nothing to knock it down which
tells me that either they're clueless
from a PR standpoint which they're not
or that there's something to it right is
what I tend to believe I agreed to yes
the fact that they've gone crickets or
made no defining statement about it to
me thinks that makes me think that
there's something there it's being
thought about whatever it may be and
then even on the other side of that you
could also argue the same type of thing
with Brady right I mean we know he's got
a friendship with Jimmy Garoppolo they
work together we saw them at the
Kentucky Derby last year on NBC all
those things you know you would think if
that was out there right and you were a
guy like Tom Brady and you're like damn
it looks like people are trying to think
say I'm stealing my friend's job across
the country you know if that weren't
true I feel like you know I don't know
I'm just trying to put myself in his
shoe right you're right I would come on
man it'd be indignant right I would be
coming up Nick not not right no that's
not real I'm not trying to go to the
49ers that's not a real thing and we're
not hearing that either so those are all
things that again not that we know but
you and I do this a lot and we read a
lot and we know some things and we
connect dots and this is how dots work
in the NFL and to me the things that are
not being said are the biggest clues
right now in this story I can't believe
anyone would suggest that I'm thinking
about trying to take my good friends job
right so I gotta say the exact not true
right right yeah that's what that's what
he could have texted to charlie weis not
nobody knows anything hey Charlie I
can't believe people think I'd actually
try to take Jimmy Garoppolo job right
that's all you got to say that's right
it's done and it's over now now from
Brady's perspective there's value in
this vague notion that saloons are
interested because he's trying to shake
the tree and see who all is going to
show up sure and the one guy that's
going to show up at some point is Bill
Belichick Tom Curren wrote over the
weekend obviously he covers the Patriots
for our colleagues at NBC Sports Boston
Tom Curren said that when it comes down
to
it's Bella checks call Robert Kraft the
owner of the team is not going to
intervene if there's a significant gap
between what the Patriots are putting on
the table and what Tom Brady would want
and look I get that because hey Bella
checks gotta want the guy and that's the
one thing that we never talked about in
this overall analysis and situation what
does Bill want he's not gonna tell us
between him and josh mcdaniels they know
better than anyone whether or not tom
brady is playing at the level that they
deem acceptable is he making good
decisions is he staying in the pocket
long enough is he moving in the pocket
like he used to yeah how's he going
through his progressions is he running
our offense the way he always has is he
is as good as he'd been is he better is
he worse they know and they got it
they're gonna lose him at some point in
the next few years for them this may be
the best opportunity to rip the band-aid
off in one motion and get somebody else
so what Bill wants is a huge factor in
this yeah sure and I feel like we're not
paying enough attention to that angle no
I think you're right I mean bill bill as
we know and josh mcdaniels first off
always have master plans especially bill
and you know I don't think anything he
does is not done without hours and hours
of thinking it out talking to people
that he trusts within that building
whoever that may be and figuring these
situations out and yeah you know I don't
think it's like totally no I don't want
Brady back I think the big question is
hey I'll have you back Tom but I'm not
paying you thirty or thirty five million
dollars and that to me is the other big
question Mike like what's that number
that you the gap is not too big right
let's just say Tennessee you're in San
Francisco are offering Brady you know 25
million a year does he go back to New
England for 20 or is that five really
enough for him to say now I'm leaving
town and I feel disrespected or whatever
that may be you know that's to me gonna
be the interesting thing here and
hopefully we'll get an inkling through
you know the media or people in the node
as far as how far off they are there and
what New England's really willing to pay
and it's not the dollars as much as it's
the message that yams from the dollars
right you're making the guy an offer you
know he's going to refuse it's it's an
offer that is
respectful enough but there's a message
in there like and that's the challenge
now if Bill Belichick even cares about
this think about how fascinating this is
you want to put a number on the table
that if it gets out there some will say
Tom should have taken it yeah but it
can't be so much that he says I'll take
it like some and and here's the thing
even though Bill Belichick has got to be
very difficult to read Tom Brady's been
reading him for 20 years in truth I
think Tom's gonna know if Bill's really
into the idea of continuing the
relationship or not
and at some point Tom may say hey Bill
look I'm gonna be direct with you do you
want me here yes or no and he's gonna
know within 10 seconds after finishing
that question what Bill Belichick wants
because he's gonna be able to read the
reaction even though Bill's always the
same he's gonna be able to read it if
bill says why do you think that of
course I want you yeah he wants him
right if he says okay yep he doesn't
really want me he'll take me back but he
has other these other things in his
plans or you know other visions of this
future what it looks like at the
quarterback position you're right I mean
that's what we're gonna find out
hopefully that's what's gonna be fun
about this last week here and hopefully
we start to get some more news and
chatter about where it may go to me
again I'm not backing off from what I
said last week I think it's a two-team
race there's just no way Brady's going
to any of these other teams if the team
can't win the Super Bowl in 2020 you're
out of it you're out and that's why I
think it's Titan Titans or Niners all
the way so it's either stay in New
England or go to Titans Niners or its
Titans and I understand you know I think
no English oh yes I'm still giving New
England the edge I still think so two
three team rate team race excuse me yes
I'm always including New England but yes
after that it's the Titans and 49ers I
think it's those three teams and that's
all there is to it and we're gonna see
how it plays out and you know I don't
know
Brady's plays a part of this Ryan
Tannehill how much money he's commanding
in this that's gonna be part of this
conversation and of course the 49ers
which were clueless about we don't know
how they feel about Jimmy G in the Brady
situation all together but we all
believe that they're interested in Brady
they gotta be at least thinking about it
or we would have heard it all getting
chopped down by now and they may chop it
down at some point this week and and and
our reaction maybe all they were never
interested no that just means they've
come to a conclusion
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports